let's talk a little more about this
loyalty pledge that Republicans and the
Republican National Committee want every
candidate who is vying for the
Republican primary to sign in advance of
participating in any debates we talked
about this last week many of you wrote
to me about it and we have more about it
I'll remind you what's going on the RNC
and the Republican Party want every
single candidate who's running to agree
in advance even if I lose I will support
whoever is eventually the Republican
nominee really the concern here is Trump
why well Trump is a child and Trump puts
himself above everything above party
above everything and so it's a
legitimate risk to the Republican party
that Trump might run in the Republican
primary but lose maybe DeSantis wins
maybe who knows somebody else wins and
then Trump instead of saying hey you
know what I lost Farin Square I'm going
to support the person that won I mean
it's like laughable that he would do
that right Trump instead will say well
you know what it was stolen it was
rigged and I'm going to run as an
independent and show these Republicans
whose boss and the reason that this
would be so devastating to the party is
there are so many states where the
margins are always thin whether it's a
Republican or a Democrat who wins
everything from Florida Pennsylvania
Ohio Michigan Wisconsin Arizona there's
so many states where it's always pretty
close
if Trump ran as an independent and took
just five to seven percent of the
Republican vote it would guarantee that
the Democratic candidate wins Trump
running as an independent could
guarantee one of the biggest Democratic
victories in 2024 that we've seen in
decades so they've asked him to sign a
loyalty pledge they're asking everybody
to sign a loyalty pledge and one of the
things that came up last week was Trump
isn't going to do this but now there's a
different perspective now the
perspective for many of you is oh Trump
will do it he just won't abide by it
well on CNN Ronald McDaniel was asked by
Dana Bash about this entire loyalty
pledge scenario and here's what she had
to say I want you to listen to what
former president Donald Trump said a
couple of weeks ago in an interview with
uh conservative radio host Hugh Hewitt
on this very topic please
if you're not the nominee will you
support whoever the GOP nominee is it
would depend I would I would give you
the same answer I gave in 2016 during
the debate it would have to depend under
the nominee was
so are you prepared to block the former
president in 2016. he did everybody
signed it in 2016. but this is about the
here and the now we didn't commit to it
I think they're all going to sign it I
really do I think the voters are very
intent on winning and they do not want
to see a debate stage of people saying
I'm not going to support this guy I'm
not going to support this guy what they
need to say is I'm going to do
everything I can to defeat Joe Biden and
that means supporting the nominee of the
Republican party you can't see a
scenario where Donald Trump would just
skip the debate if he's forced to sign
something you want to be on the debate
stage I think president Trump would like
to be on the debate stage that's what he
likes to do and I expect they'll all be
there so listen
I actually have revised my view a little
bit last week I was really leaning
towards Trump's never going to sign this
thing and they will capitulate and let
them on the stage because otherwise
their voters will you know start a
mutiny I actually now believe the more
likely scenario is Trump will sign
whatever he needs to sign to get to the
debate stage he'll play Coy if and when
the question comes up during the debates
but then if he loses he'll say screw
that pledge it's not legally binding it
means nothing I signed it but then when
I signed it I I meant if they if they
fairly win they didn't fairly defeat me
so I'm going to go and run as an
independent anyway if that's what he
wants to do the point is Trump's
completely dishonest in this way
and the more I think about it I can't
think of any
anyone who knows Trump at all the way we
do because we've been following him for
so long who thinks he would actually
come out and just say I am going to
support this person that just defeated
me it's very difficult to imagine that
that's the case the interview had
another interesting moment uh which was
about accepting the results of 2024 and
Ronald McDaniel also plays koi with this
she goes oh yeah no I think all the
candidates will accept the 2024 results
because we're going to win which is
exactly the language that got us into
the 2020 mess to begin with Thomas when
we're talking about promises now that
whomever the Republican nominee is yeah
ultimately will accept the results in
2024. I expect that they will accept the
results in 2024. I I'm not I don't know
who that person is right now but yes
we're gonna accept the results
um and we're going to move forward and
work to to govern this country but I
think they're going to accept the
results because they're going to be the
president
well that doesn't really Inspire
confidence raw saying they will accept
it either way is different than there's
going to be no reason not to accept it
because the Republican can that it will
have won so listen it's not a big
surprise but they are already gearing up
for the same election denying nonsense
in 2024 let's not get ahead of ourselves
on that there's time to get to that but
just know they are setting it up
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below